هو في هجوم علاقات عامة ،
فهو يأمل أن القلوب والعقول في
منطقة شرطة كابول التي يديرها الآن
لا يحمل سلاحًا ، لكن دعمه
يقوم
بمقاتلي طالبان الجدد من الخطوط الأمامية
حاملين أسلحة أمريكية يرتدون ملابس
قتالية.
أهم
الأحياء في وسط كابول ،
الحي المالي ،
يمثل أمنه أولوية
لطالبان
مع سمعة طالبان المبررة جيدًا
بالوحشية ، يجب أن تكون
مهمة سهلة بالنسبة إلى حقاني المخضرم البالغ من العمر 17 عامًا
للسيطرة
ولكن
ليس كيف يتم ذلك.  يشعر بأنه يقوم
بحراسة الشوارع بدلاً من
القتال للسيطرة على البلد
، يقول إنه سعيد لخدمة الأمة
تمامًا كما كان من قبل لجلب الشريعة الإسلامية
إلى المدينة ولكن هناك الكثير من
الناس الكثير من الفساد والكثير من
السرقة  تخلصوا مما قاله ،
لقد اعتاد نشر أكان أن يكون وظيفة شرطة البرقوق في المدينة ،
الكثير من المال الكثير من
الابتزازات تشعر
بالسير هنا أن الناس لا
يزالون  قليل الحذر بشأن طالبان
ولكن في نفس الوقت الذي يخرجون فيه إلى
الشوارع يتاجرون ، فإنهم يمارسون
أعمالهم ،
لذا يبدو الأمر وكأنه يستقر
ولكن هذا النوع من الشعور بعدم الارتياح في أي
اتجاه سنذهب
نحن  سعيدًا ، أخبرني تاجر الذهب هذا أنه
لا يوجد فساد حتى الآن يمكنني ترك العمل
بعد حلول الظلام ، فهذا أكثر أمانًا ،
فكيف هو الوضع هنا الآن
المؤسسة جيدة جدًا كما تعلمون إذا
رأيت منذ عامين مضت
نرى اللصوص والسرقة هنا ولا
يقين  هنا الآن نتحدث عن
أه أتمنى إن شاء الله تتمتع
بحياة جيدة جدًا
مع طالبان على مرمى البصر ، من
الصعب أن نعرف على وجه اليقين كيف يشعر الناس حقًا
ولكن على الرغم من وجودهم ،
تقترب منا العديد من النساء الشجاعات
هذه المرأة التي كانت قريبة من البكاء تخبرني
أنها أرملة  مع ستة أطفال فصلتها طالبان
من وظيفة حكومية أرسلتها إلى
منزلها بدون
أجر ونحن نتحدث.
دفع een مقابل الشهر المقبل ولكن
ليس لديه أي فكرة عما سيحدث بعد ذلك ،
الأمر متروك لـ hakarni لاختيار ما إذا
كان سيكون حازمًا ومحترمًا أو
قويًا ومخوفًا مثل طالبان قبل
أن يقول في الوقت الحالي لا توجد خطط
لقطع أيدي اللصوص كما كان من
قبل بأي طريقة.  سيقدم بقشيشًا رائدًا للبلد